欢迎收看最佛心幽默的财经节目
理财达人秀
我是李兆华
好 8月快要过完了
今天星期五
我们创下了一个反弹后的新高哦
而且今天的量呢
也有微微放大到一兆左右
整个8月截至目前为止
已经创下了外资最大的单月买超纪录
哎 外资好像确确实实的回头了
而景气灯号也开出了第八颗的红灯
好走到这里大家观察今天盘面上会发现哦
不止一些领头羊在涨之外
今天涨的倒有蛮多事
大家心里面很喜爱
但是这段时间反弹不见得很多的哦
例如说像金居金像店金元店等等的
甚至像被动元件的国具性仓店
所以大家的心里面都会很希望呢
是不是这些比较落后的
但是以前大家好喜欢的股票
能够接棒继续往上攻
那这一波会这么的强
我想挥打真的功不可没
真的把魔咒给破除了
连续实际
这个所谓财报后的下跌
在昨天晚上彻底颠覆
大涨了八个多个百分点
好 那气势到下个礼拜
能不能延续
还是会出现转折
我想这个真的非常重要
所以我们来欢迎今天的三位来宾
好 第一位是盈利投资的
中国庄 中总
好 中大胆一定要提醒大家
虽然今天创下了反弹高
但是我们还有一件事情
大家都忘了吗
全球央行年会要开了
所以在这个部分利率恐怕还是盘面上
我们一定要关注的一件事情
会不会带来一些些的压力
但是呢今天盘面上像被动元件
这种比较落后反弹的
诶弹起来了
它到底能不能满血复活
关键就在于里面有成分股是MSCI
这是要调整的时候要新增的
中大胆很关注这件事
所以会告诉大家
这一次MSCI的换股里面
独家帮您看
后续延续性强的好股票
已经扫描出来了
第二位是我们的国家级基金操盘手
黄丰凯 凯哥
凯哥也要讲
虽然回答了财报
交出好成绩
可是麦威尔的财报
大家却有点压力了
到底在跌什么
可是麦威尔跌我们的CPU
没有跌
我们的发哥拉尾盘
这些都有原因
再来我们看投信
虽然外资大买
但投信这波的方向比较不明朗
被投信丢掉的
例如像贪政系列
或者像之前大家喜欢的
金像店 联店
有没有可能捡回来呢
另外今天新发生的一件事
星星我们的载版龙头
被捡掉搜索了
投信今天是跑不掉的
下个礼拜一到底该如何处置
凯哥会告诉您他的方案
好 第三位呢
是我们的当冲铺段
双刀流高献荣
好 献荣也在关注
外资一直买
单月的历史买超新高
真沒想到前七個月
把我們賣的亂七八糟
所以憲榮今天也是獨家幫您看了
外資持續買超
而且今年的營收年增率
超過35個百分點的有底氣
外資加持的是哪些
另外大戶也在持續佈局
佈局電力股
為何如此不離不棄
等一下告訴您
他心目中的好標的
好 首先有請總總
早好
總總這個禮拜五
是創下了反彈新高
但是你也會提醒大家
我們的央行年會
全球央行聯會還沒開
等一下要怎麼關注
被動國際性倉電已經回血了
能不能繼續呢
MSCI的換股大戲
是您一項最關注的
那當然我想這幾天
大家市場上最關注的重點
就是全球央行聯會最深厚
那我們包括我們看過去
歷年來的最深厚開完之後
這個標準500
標普500的部分
大家可以看到
包括從葉倫到豹爾的時代來看
演說的當天大概是上
其實這邊的上漲機率都高
就七成以上 看起來是很高
但是今年面臨到通膨高於目標
而且美債殖利率最近的攀升
以及政府的債務膨脹的一些壓力市場未必會再給出現一個正面的反应那尤其这个费得如果让这个通膨回落到2%政治还不明朗不过我个人认为说
华许应该不会有激烈的言论
不过要注意一下是
日本升息几率可能会比较高
因为之前包括高市
有曾经提到过
可能会在9月的部分
日元可能会做升息
那我们再回头再来看一下
全球股市的部分
道琼指数在这一波当中
我们之前一提到
它一直沿着这条月线在走
但是先前最强是倒穷指数
创新高之后拉回
但是昨天出现一个大量
大量又没有上涨
换句话说表示说
这个走势还不是很稳定
只能算是慢慢要连
台积日在挥打的激励情况之下
那这边来讲就是
被你到之前提到过
一个下降的压力线位置
那当然这两天就是观察
它这个部分的下降的趋势
能不能突破
如果没有突破
那相对来讲
它可能还是进行一个
匣间的盘整的部分
我想这就是有关于
这个补市的部分
至于再回头来看台股
台股呢
这礼拜量说价涨
这边量这样子
只有4.07兆
那今天来看的话
量是有稍微到一兆多
不过一兆多呢
开始又面临到一个问题
上次我提到过
每次达到1.1兆
就是开始面临到一个叫做
你丢我减的
或者籌碼的换手的动作
上次因为会来到4万6千多
是因为双I效应
就上次我提到过
这个升息降区环
CPI
还有一个CPI
那这次有机会又来到
今天有亏达的效应
那今天刚好突破一兆多
不过各位也不要忘记
今天一兆多
但是今天有一个副台子结算
如果没有副台子结算
肯定要一兆
可能有点连想还轻
换句话说
这两天你要继续观察
把這個量 能夠在1兆以上
為什麼 因為要把先前
上市在這個月中的時候
這部分的1.1兆
要順便要做一個換手的成功
才能夠往上推
所以我個人認為說
這個46,500點數附近不追高
但是拉回來是可以做一個買進的動作
那我個人認為說
還是會進行一個區間整理
前坡這邊46,350附近
你還是把手中止補降低
極短線 我講極短線就是
大概45,000這附近
月線這邊 對
那8月份今天雖然還有
還有一天的交易日
不過8月份確定應該是量縮價漲
因為上個月有21兆
這個月只有17兆多
所以這波應該是
立為一個跌升反彈的格局
需要再反覆的整理動作
再來就是要看一下OTC的部分
OTC在這波當中
已經來到這個季線
還有極限位置
上次也是在這邊採到壓力
我覺得今天要注意一下
OTC的融資的部分
如果你特別注意一下
台灣的融資
尤其是在上櫃的部分更明顯
你會發現上面的走勢圖
跟融資走勢圖是一本一模一樣
那所以換句話說你看
從這個8月初到現在
這個走勢基本上就一模一樣
換句話說如果這邊的融資有再增加
相對這個大盤挑戰
這個季線壓力就非常高
那相反如果是說到這個季線
這邊融資有出現減少
或是甚至再往下降一些
那可能這部分力道
可能就是會稍微弱一點
我想這個部分是要注意一下
今天晚上公布的這融資的變化
好 所以希望融資反而增加
願意增加買盤
聰明融資 沒錯
今天這個被動元件
在這個輝打的效應
是
也幾率稍微一些
現前沒漲到
因為我們知道
之前都先漲CPU
還有其他這些相關的載板
或等等的
但是一直漲不起來的
被動元件因為籌碼因素
所以今天可以看到
何生堂今天出現掌停板
那其他還有包括華新科
還有國劇
當然最主要市場關心的是國劇部分
還有日電貿 信倉店這邊
那我抓兩家公司給大家做參考所以我個人認為說被動元件是未來是可以稍微去特別再注意除了它的這次的漲幅乖離不是很高之外
下禮拜MACI會把
和聲糖納進去
和聲糖
那再來就是被動元件
目前的一現場
它相對位階是在高
像國際是還在
剛好從低檔起來
相對已經到了
上次的這個位置區
更何況這邊有大量位置
換句話說
如果這波的一現場
要往上攻 核上膛
絕對是下禮拜要關注的重點
因為它是被納入MACI的新成分股
如果被納入MACI的新成分股
還不會帶動其他的整個族群的話
那這個族群就可能要
就辛苦一點
是 再另外一個就是日電報
那日電報我為什麼抓這家公司
去做參考是因為
這個是屬於攻擊組
這個是屬於防守組
那今年來講
我大概算一算明年的股利
應該有機會配到9塊
殖利率5%
換句話說這個相對低
哇 它談不太動
因為說穩健型的人
如果在這個位置
你明年殖利率可能就5%左右
所以是攻守
我認為說都已經在做一個
具備等機會了
好
那這是下禮拜MEC要生效的公司
今天怎麼漲跌那麼劇烈
因為CPU的部分
我今天沒有特別會提到
是因為這一波先漲多的
先拉回
為什麼 你會發現
今天跌的都比較多
就是像之前本益比的
像CPU的有沒有
有些比較大的
都今天反而下跌
今天反而是
本益比比较合理的啦
坦白講這邊基本上本益比都算高的
都是四五十以上
所以你會發現到今天的京居
和珊黨他們的本益比都50倍
以今年目前佔顧了本益比來看
其他來講像藍郡國際也是一樣
所以你會發現
因為靠近的時候他本來是買這個
像今天肩點也漲滿多
這個65%
那是因為聯合再生是9%
不過是靠業外
本地還是虧損的
那當然還有一些
連有金屬創 配爾生意創
就因為版面是要放不下
這個創 你就自己去
創新版
好 那這時候會放那個是因為
各位看一下 這上個月
上一次 5月19號
MCI的時間
因為每季都會幫大家做追蹤
MCI納入成分股
真的有沒有值得去追蹤
確實有
它大概上次
大概新納入的一些新的成分股
大概有將近有8檔到9檔
那裡面順德創新高
這邊又插起來
最標準厲害 台虹
放在這邊 不怎麼樣子
到最後面竟然漲一倍
PTFE材料
差一倍 所以換句話說
哪一黨會被下次被向中
會做一個所謂任陽股
特別做賬股
那就大家就再隨意做
當然下次我也再幫大家做追蹤
對 好
那今天我會講兩家公司
一家是京區
還有一家是非電的部分
首先我們看電子的京區
坦白講電子這個本益比50倍
不是我會喜歡 喜歡看的
不過在裡面看下去
在本益比合理的
我覺得看得比較順眼的
就真的只有京區
好 高階同伯
真的是不容易就是它
因為什麼
首先看它營業的部分
確實每個月的營業
YY將近有四五成
算是一個成長型的
那前七個月將近有45%左右
那其實上TATA
之前研發一些相關的這個
算是高頻高速的超低速照度的通勃
對整個目前AI的發展來講
它算是很重要的部分
再來就是重點是各位看
它的營業率成長
現在到上半年的話將近有25%
比之前的18% 16%
坦白講有擴大的部分
上半年EPS 4.2
如果按照這樣的話
市場上預估
今天EPS保守應該有10%一個資本額
營業率我剛才提到創新高
所以看起來的話
它目前來講應該是有機會
會在下一次季度當中被特別關照
那股利率的部分大概不高
因為這個算是高價股的成長股
那我們來看一下它的股價走勢坦白講這篇的股價走勢它之前最高來到754.55那這一波当中一口气涨很多没有上车的反正在这波当中下来打回原点你会发现一个现况
这边都没有什么套牢区
抢短的没有怎么讲抢短
换句话说
为什么我们说这边你可以留意
是因为在这波过程当中
就线来看
所有的均线都在下面
换句话说
近一年近半年近一季
大家的成本都一样
而且这个返航过程当中
最主要是在这波当中
只有这边量比较大
还有这边比较大
但是你现在目前位置
还有一点点的距离
所以这边的强短空间
套牢的强
这个所谓的强
强这个短线的人比较少
我个人觉得这部分
应该是有机会
如果未来有拉肥的话
我想这边有机会呈现一个
超级黄金的交叉点部分
所以我想这个部分是可以
可以对于
今天已经过了季线的位置
金居我们算常送暖的
這是電子的部分
那非電的部分呢
就來講一個雷虎
也要受暖了
這個條例預算通過
怎麼今天黑壓壓的一片
因為電子有一部分
我抓一個非電
那為什麼要放這無人機
無人機今天看起來預算通過
怎麼今天看起來
好像開高總體不開心
我們先講一下它的部分
通過無人機的預算
基本上就是產業成長
就是趨勢又更確立
那營業的部分
現在目前大概是
沒有怎麼特別成長
因為我還簽這個預算通過
但是整體看起來
目前已經有改善 為什麼
它的營運率的部分
負得0.26%
慢慢好一點
不過第二屆營運率
已經有0.1%
那下個月9月15號
國際塑膠的工業長
在9月15號登場
翰翔跟雷虎
會去被邀請分享
這個前瞻的技術
相關的這些的零件的
這個應用的部分
重點是非獨立董先持股
6月份上次我也來
特別提到過650張
然後6月份是受169.5
好那存貨已經比上次
第一季來的低
上次是25%
現在已經降到23%左右
那下一次呢
下個禮拜我為什麼說
可以看特別看這個無人機的部分
因為下個禮拜9月3號
有一家新公司掛牌
下有3718中光電投控
中光電投控原來就叫做中光電
從一天一股換一股
所以下個禮拜
你會想說奇怪
最近人家買5371
怎麼中光店不見
因為現在現在就要換股當中
下禮拜9月3號
所以我想下禮拜
如果中光店要剛掛牌的話
會不會有所謂的一些
所謂的慶祝效應我不知道
但是如果看起來的話
這個部分可以去值得觀察
畢竟剛換完之後
然後馬上就那個不好
還蠻奇怪的
當然我們現在看
剛剛我提到過
6月份的非獨立董堅持股
增加是在這個位置
那說法在這位要
那換句話說
你現在位階
坦白講
你覺得位階較高還較低
好 算偏低
那因為9月份呢
這次來講的話
行政院要把這個部分
送到總統府
那總統府要做一個
要看完之後
然後再去邀給行政院
再做附屬
所以我想9月份
因此這個預算
無人間預算
應該還是市場上會關注的
重點之一的部分
好 因為它走成一座山
對不對 現在在整理
所以總總是覺得後續來說
其實預算通過
對軍工股整體還是有利
我個人覺得說
你不要去看這個什麼
什麼這個所謂的成交量問題
因為沒過的話
也是差不多這
有過至少表示未來這個比
是越來越會大
只是說早晚的問題
如果今天股價是在這位階
那你可能就要考慮到這問題
如果位階是在這裡
那我個人就覺得
這部分的可能或許
要把先前這邊的籌碼
稍微做一個適當的換手整理
除非你就換一個角度
我常常讲
无染机预算通过
它以后股票是这样跌
那就很奇怪
顶多就是这样子
另外一种就是这样子
我想这个部分应该
这个跟这个的可能性比较高
这个部分应该是比较小一些
好 这边非常谢谢董总
好 谢谢赵华